[MUSIC PLAYING]
If you build a game for
iOS or Android using Unity,
I'd love to see it
on my TV, and you
can do so by using the Google
Cast Display plug-in for Unity.
We've put together
an Android code lab
showing you how to do so.
So let's take a look.
Let's get started with
adding Cast's support
to an existing game in Unity.
First thing we do is we
open an existing project.
We'll open this project that
we've called Begin Project,
and then we'll fire up
inside the Unity IDE.
Now that we're actually
inside the IDE,
we could try
playing this project
as is by pressing
the Play button.
Now we see the game
running, and we
can explore our world,
fire, do all sorts of stuff,
and hopefully not get killed.
Now that we know
the game is working,
we can start by adding
support for the Android
SDK inside Unity.
To set up the Android
SDK inside Unity,
first you need to
tell it where it is.
So you go to Preferences,
External Tools,
look for the Android
SDK line, choose Browse,
and locate the position
on your hard disk,
where you've actually
installed the Android SDK.
In this case, it's right here.
So I click Choose,
and now Unity is
ready to work with
the Android SDK.
Next we'll need to configure
the Android player so that Unity
will build for Android.
What we do is we click the File
Menu, choose Build Settings,
then look for
Android in the list,
select it, if it's
not already selected,
and click Switch
Platform to make it
the default build target.
While that happens, it will
start importing the assets
and getting ready to build
an Android application.
After we've imported
everything for Android,
we now need to configure
the bundle identifier.
Come over here to the
Player Settings button.
If you click that, you'll see
over here in the Inspector
we have the Play Settings.
We click on Other Settings.
It brings up a whole
lot of options.
First thing we do is we
change the bundle identifier.
So for our example,
we'll just set it
to something like example.game.
We also need to change
the minimum API version
because the Cast
plug-in requires
Android KitKat 4.4 or higher,
so we choose 4.4 KitKat.
Now that we've
configured everything,
we can just close the
Build Settings dialog.
And if we save our project
by going File, Save Project,
we can then go
File, Build & Run.
What we should do at
this point in time
is actually connect
an Android device.
So we'll plug it in, click
Build & Run, and hopefully,
build our application
to run on our phone,
and we'll call the project game.
Now, while we wait
for that to build,
we'll get on to the next thing,
which is actually playing
the game to see how it works.
Now we have our game running
on the phone, so swipe
from the top to the home
screen and quit the game.
Next, we'll get on the Cast,
enabling the game itself.
To begin development of
your Cast-enabled game,
you need to go to the
Cast Developer Console.
On the console, you can
add new applications
that will run on the Cast
device and register devices
for debugging.
So we'll click Add
New Application
and choose the Remote
Display Receiver type.
This will receive the
content from your phone.
So we'll call it My Game.
Once you click Save, you will
be issued an application ID
that you can see here.
You'll use that in your project.
The other thing we need to do
is register a debugging device.
If I click the Add
New Device button,
whilst this dialogue is up, I
can click the Cast extension
in Chrome, which will show me
Cast device that are available.
If you don't have
the extension, you
can get it from the
Chrome Web Store.
If I click on that device, it
will show the serial number
and read it out to me, so I
can enter the serial number
into my dialog box here.
So the serial number
that it's read to me
for this particular
example I'll just
type in and give it a name.
And we'll call it PlayRoom.
Now, when we click
OK, what you'll see
is a registering dialogue.
Now this status here registering
takes approximately 15 minutes
to complete.
So this is good time go and get
a cup of coffee and come back.
After your device is
registered for development,
you'll see these
Ready For Testing
status in the Cast
Developer Console.
At this point, you should
reboot your Cast device,
and we'll get ready to set
up the Google Cast plug-in.
Now that we've set up
our device for testing,
we need to download the Google
Cast Remote Display plug-in
from the Unity Asset Store.
Once we've downloaded it,
we can go back into Unity,
choose Assets, Import
Package, Custom Package,
and then select the
plug-in and click Open.
This will bring up an
input package dialogue.
Here we click the Import
button to all the assets
into our project.
After the plug-in has finished
loading all the assets,
you should be able to go down
here to the Plug-ins folder
and check you have all the
folders for the Google Cast
Remote Display plug-in
available to you.
Note, at that this
point, we need
to copy three of the
Android SDK libraries
into the Plug-ins folder.
That's the google-play-services
library, the appcompat library,
and the mediarouter library.
Now that we've set
up the plug-in,
we need to go to the
Android directory
and open the
Android.manifest.xml file.
You'll see it over
here in the Inspector.
Now, if we bring it
up in our editor,
we need to change
the package name
to be the same as what
we set up in Unity.
So we set it as example.game
save the manifest file.
The next thing we need to
do is add an audio listener
to our project so that we can
send audio the Cast device.
We go up to the Assets
menu, choose Assets, Create,
C# Script, and then
we'll rename that to be
AudioListenerSingleton.
Now we open that file
up in a text editor,
and we can actually
change the code
to implement the
audio listener for us.
The example is in the code lab
referenced from this video.
Next we need to add the
audio listener to the scene.
But to do that, we
go to Game Object,
Create an Empty Game Object.
We can rename that to the be
our AudioListenerSingleton.
And if we navigate down
into our Plug-ins folder,
where the Google Cast
Remote Display plug-in is,
you'll see the audio
listener inside there.
So we select it, and
we drag it and drop it
onto our AudioListenerSingleton.
You'll notice that the
display on the right here
in the Inspector has changed to
show the script we just added.
Meanwhile, we need
to add the script we
created in the previous step.
So we go back into the
Android folder, where
we had created that script, find
that AudioListenerSingleton,
and drag it on as well.
You'll see the
second script up here
in the right-hand inspector.
Now what we need to do is
actually add the remote display
to the scene, and
we'll be all done.
Now let's add remote
display to the Unity scene.
What we need to do is go to
the Google Cast Remote Display
folder here and find this prefab
called Google Remote Display
Manager and drag it
into our scene hierarchy
at the top level.
If we then select it and
go over to the right,
we need to set a few things.
First thing we set
is the Audio Manager.
We want to set it to the
AudioListenerSingleton
we created in the
previous step so that we
can send audio to the device.
Next, we need to
create a camera.
After you've added the
Cast Remote Display Manager
to your project, you
need to set the app ID
so that the Cast device knows
which app to load, which
is over here in the Inspector.
So what we do is we go back to
our Cast SDK Developer Console,
grab that ID, and copy it.
Once we've copied the ID,
we can put it into Unity,
so now we know-- the
Cast device knows
which application to load.
Next, we'll add
the mobile camera.
To create the camera, we
choose Game Object, Camera.
This is the camera
that will show
the image on the mobile
phone when casting,
so we'll call it
the mobile camera.
Now, if we select
the mobile camera,
we need to remove the
Audio Listener over here
because it can interfere
with our audio routing
to the Cast device, so
we remove the component.
We also need to remove
it from the main camera.
So we go across here
to the Audio Listener
and get rid of it.
Now that we've
created the cameras,
we need to wire in a script
that will control them.
To prepare the script
to control the camera,
we go to the File System and
go to end_project, Assets,
Scripts, Camera, and find the
RemoteCameraManager.cs script
file.
We take that, and we'll copy
it over into our project.
So if we drop it
in there, we have
the script for the
mobile camera, which
provides the view for the
mobile device during casting,
and the main camera, which
is shown on the Cast device.
Now that we've copied the
script, we get back to Unity
and set it up for use.
If we go into the
Scripts, Camera folder,
you'll see the
RemoteCameraManager there.
We just grab it and drag
it onto our Mobile Camera.
Then if we look at the Mobile
Camera in our Inspector,
we can see the script enabled.
We need to change a
few settings here.
Change the Display Manager to
be the CastRemoteDisplayManager.
We'll also set the Remote
Display Camera to be the Mobile
Camera that we've just built.
Then, of course, the Main
Camera will be the Main Camera.
So now we've set
up all our cameras.
We're ready to go.
What we need to do is
add some kind of UI
to allow casting to happen.
To set up a simple UI to
start casting from our phone
to the display, we go back into
the Google Cast Remote Display
Plug-ins folder and
find the Cast Default
UI, which is a prefab
that provides a Cast UI.
We drag that into the top
level of our hierarchy,
and that will give us a nice UI.
And we're ready to go.
All we need to do now is
choose File, Build And Run,
and watch it run on our iPhone.
So we've built our game,
and, lo and behold,
it has a Cast
icon, which lets us
send the game play to any
Google Cast enabled device.
For more details, go
to the code lab, which
explains how to make the
Cast icon transparent,
change colors, and add
controls to move your player
around the game so it
actually does something.
I hope you enjoyed a quick
tour through how to make
your game Google Cast enabled.